this meal I'll hum did allah assalamu
alaikom which means peace be unto you
the same greeting that moses greeted his
followers with the same greeting that
jesus greeted his followers with and the
same greeting that the last and final
messenger sent to mankind greeted his
followers with and that is the greetings
of peace by the way it's the same way of
life the same way of life that Jesus by
the way called his followers to and
Moses and Abraham and all the messengers
of God which was that way that way of
submission to the one God worshiping him
alone and not his creation this is that
way of life
that we're calling you to here today
Islam and this is what we're talking
about some of the beautiful teachings
that the last and final messenger
brought for all of mankind so we're
gonna be talking about something that
all of us are going to have to face
something that is very serious but many
of us are forgetting about it not
thinking about it death are you prepared
for it it's coming you've got an
appointment with it
so we're going to be discussing it not
according to our whims and desires but
according to the last and final
revelation sent to mankind which is the
Quran and the authentic teachings of the
last and final messenger who was sent to
mankind so we have somebody who is very
well versed with the verbatim Word of
God the Quran and the teachings of the
last and final messenger when we come
back when I'll be talking to him so sit
tight you don't go nowhere be right back
on a Deen show
Allah there's only one word how mad is
his messenger Allah
there's only one Jesus was his messenger
no I did that maybe it maybe it's just
to break the ice
assalamualaikum chef how are you it's
good to have you back here with us live
to be here today on this show and we're
going to continue on insha'Allah God
willing to talk about something that
should be on the minds of the people
something that is very important you
know if you got an examination at school
you don't doze off you you know you
study for it but this exam
disappointment that we have death many
people they're not thinking about it so
let's start with this why do you think
this is something that people tend to
either make a joke about they think this
is something left for the movies
something that you know it's you know
they know they're gonna face it but they
just ignore it and then if somebody
tries to someone who is serious it tries
to bring something up about this is
something odd you know what they change
the subject
making u-turn go the other way and just
dodged it why do you think is a shape
just from the love salatu salam on so
left the reason this is happening and
most of the human beings unless those
who are lost panel to allah have mercy
on that are basically in state of
forgetfulness the same way they would
seek intoxications to feel good about
themselves to be in a state of not in
their mind and not to be serious of what
is coming ahead this is the serious
diseases that we need to as muslims to
educate ourselves and to educate others
about the reality of things we're not
trying to be pessimistic and call people
to be sad and misery in life actually
it's the opposite when somebody is
knowing what is coming ahead and being
serious about it and taking the
precautions and the means to have a good
way of life in this life and the
happiness in it and what comes after for
people just to think to think and allah
subhanaw taala in the quran he called
people to ponder over things not to be
always seeking ways of intoxications
just been state of forgetfulness to
think and to ponder over how things are
around us and it's mentioned the quran
when it comes to death for us as muslims
it's not a time of being sad and misery
when we remember death we
this is the order of Allah silent and
most panel terraces in the Quran in
solitude mulk Tabarrok and levy beardy
in Monaco or ala kulli shayin Qadir and
levy halat and moto and higher Thalia
below Akuma Akuma tsunami that a most
panorama is the most exalted he's the
one that created life and death for what
purpose so that he would test you a
monkey who is the best of the deeds
among you so god allah subhanaw taala is
the most twice so death is not just
something that happens without a wisdom
like this happens by the great and the
perfect wisdom of Allah subhana WA
Ta'ala for the test of the human beings
and for them to prepare themselves and
it's a period of time that we have to
live on this earth and then after that
everybody shall return to Allah
subhanAllah
you know what this you know when we did
some of these Arabic returns we got a
lot of non-muslims and they hear you
know this sound going off but now
there's warning us that we need to
define some words they heard the term
Muslim and they heard the term lost
front dollar so can you take a second
before we continue on just to define
what a Muslim is and what Quran is and
what is a law so people have a more
familiarity with these terms the word
Muslim means someone that submitted
himself to the creator of the heavens
and earth and if actually we take away
the word Muslim and the word Islam and
we just talk about the translation of it
I think this is what every human being
should detest to and should believe in
we are created we are creation of the
creator of the heavens and the earth and
most of the human being they believe in
the creator of the heavens and the earth
and they know that he is the provider
that he's the Creator but how many of
them they submit themselves totally to
him and this submission as you mentioned
in the beginning of the show that it's
this job of every messenger that God had
sent to the human beings from Adam peace
be upon him all the way to prophet
muhammad sallallahu said I'm going
through all the messengers Abraham and
Moses and Jesus and Muhammad SAW Allah
sent them they came with that same
message which is Islam Islam is not just
some letters here that has no meaning to
it it means submit yourself to the
creator of the heavens and the earth and
it's not referring to a human being or a
certain organization or a cult or
anything like that it's the same main
coke in the core of
human being in his nature that he wants
to turn to the creator of the heavens
and earth and allah subhanaw taala he's
the creator of the heavens in year the
almighty and the same word is used in
aramaic and in arabic and it's a unique
word that nothing is the like of him but
when you say god you can make it a
plural you can say gods you can say
goddess feminine masculine things of
that nature but when you say Allah it's
nothing is the like of it and he is
nothing is the like of him and he's the
all-hearer the all-seer as it's
mentioned in the Quran alright great so
they don't probably have to take that
Arabic class not quite yet so alright
good so now the non-muslim he can kind
of get a better understanding and that's
what we're here for trying to help you
develop a better understanding on this
unique way of life that is for all
mankind
now tell us what are some of the
benefits when you think about death you
said that this is not a call to
pessimism it's actually something good
to think about them so what are some of
the benefits of a human being when he
thinks about death and he takes a time
out from this work work money money work
work party party many things about death
because this is primarily what people do
work money party when they get out of
this and they think about death talk to
us if somebody for example will be told
that an enemy will come and attack you
and enter this room on you at a time
that you don't know when but it's
definitely happening what would be that
state of that person either he will just
ignore that fact and just keep drinking
wine for example trying to forget this
method it's not gonna push it away it's
gonna happen no matter what all he
should take the matter seriously and
prepare himself so that when the attack
comes he'll be able to defend himself
and win yeah so who is among the two is
the most twice prepared everybody will
agree to this and this is why the issue
of death every single human being
believes it whether it's a believer at
this believeth someone that is a deviant
someone that is on the straight path
everybody believes that one day he has
to depart from this life so if this is
effect the most wise among the human
beings are the ones that would take the
metaseries and get to search and see the
truth what is after this if a person
asked himself these questions sincere
and then since he realized and believes
that in the creator of the heavens and
the earth and if each person have his
own wisdom and doing things this cup is
here for a reason this desk is for a
reason just things doesn't happen by
itself like this and the same way why
God created life and death for a purpose
and that is to worship Him alone and to
submit to him and to follow his
revelations in for example the
restoration which is the Quran and the
Sunnah of the Prophet SAW Allah says so
the Quran tells us that this death that
everybody runs away from flee away from
the most rich man on the face of earth
he would spend all of his wealth to save
himself from death the most precious
thing in one's life is his own life and
life is so precious of course but allah
subhanaw taala taught us in the quran
and in the son that hadees and the
sayings of the prophet sallallaahu selim
that since this is something that is
coming prepare yourself for it and if
you prepare yourself for it you'll have
the better and the best life in this
world you're not intoxicated anymore
you're having the happiness the real one
in this life and you will take it with
you in the everlasting one and if you
see the wisdom of allah subhanaw taala
on this earth that life is so limited
and every person has his own set of
amount of breaths in number once the
last one comes life is over and then
everybody shall return to allah subhanaw
taala
the Prophet peace be upon him solo
Marisela he said a very beautiful hadith
when he saw a jenessa
gen as a meaning a funeral that would
pass him by passing by he said this
jenessa this funeral the person that
died either that he will be comfortable
now or people will be comfortable by him
departing from this world he is one of
two and he said the first type is the
believer he is going to the comfort to
the real comfort going to the mercy of
allah spano that almost a note Allah is
the most merciful and we see this mercy
O Lord round us and for the believers
they return back to the mercy of Allah
so a note on but the one the disbeliever
the human beings and animals and all
that exists now they have more comfort
by him departing because he was a mean
of spreading corruption on the face of
earth and bringing sins and so on so
knowing this and knowing also that the
profits on the I seldom he said x0 will
they can I had emulate that which means
remember death a lot if you say that to
a normal person he would say what he
want us to have a miserable life it's
not it's when you remember it that means
you will prepare yourself for it that
means you will be more real and when
you're more real you'll you'll taste the
real sweetness of happiness and not the
one that is just instead of
forgetfulness yeah you mentioned and you
told us before one hadith one saying of
the last and final messenger encouraging
actually running sports remember this so
Islam encourages not to be someone who
is just isolated worshipping in the
household they not getting on society so
to be the best husband to be the best
human being possibly that you can be
according to how God wants you to be a
lot right so now by thinking about death
I want you to tell us because have you
heard this saying where the last and
final messenger had said the best among
you are those that are the best in
manners right and the the most
intelligent among you are the ones who
think of death often right now somebody
might think like intelligent don't I
need a doctor's degree PhD this is
intelligence but what did he mean by
this now the real smart person is the
one that knows what's coming ahead and
prepared himself for it that's the main
difference between the human beings and
animals animals they just follow their
immediate design they don't look ahead
yeah for the human being we look ahead
person goes to school for years because
you know the outcome of it that he would
make money whatever there is and this is
what allah sanatana ordered us in the
quran that we looked even more than that
not to just to be limited in the
tightness of this life but to look at
the spaciousness of this life and in the
hereafter and that is to prepare
ourselves for the after does that mean
that a person would run away from this
world and go to the desert of the jungle
that somewhere and just isolate himself
because some groups of people on the
face of earth when they thought and
pondered over this reality it took us
away in extremism and other group
because of what they saw and they
thought that this is what happens to
people when they think about this they
ignored this fad completely and they
said let's just enjoy whatever we have
and what death comes it come
doesn't matter what happens to us
afterwards and this is both ways of
course is not the proper way the proper
way is to realize that we have to depart
from this life and to understand that
this life is nothing but a passage to
the Hereafter
a person would not enter paradise Jenna
unless he do the right to work in this
life and a person would enter the
Hellfire as a result of their actions in
this life so we need to make this life
in such a beautiful way so that it's the
mean for us to the happy one in the
hereafter and the profits are seldom
said in a very beautiful hadith to
stress this fact in the life of the
Muslims he said if the hour occurs the
day of judgement is occurring now and in
the hand of one of you phacelia a bud or
a grass or a plant planted in the ground
what the day of judgment is happening
why should I do that
it shows the attitude that no matter
what as long as we are living in this
life we have a purpose in it we do what
is good we do what it's needed to be to
establish the acts of worship on this
face of earth and to make everything
have the the proper and the perfect
sense in which everything fits in the
worship of the creator of the heavens in
your eternal yeah this is a major I
could just continue listening to you we
are almost out of time so I want to hit
a few more points with all the
distractions with all the things that
are count the advertisers everywhere you
go especially living in the West you
have a lot of things calling you to
materialism calling you to some kind of
Solace feeling that if you buy this
you're going to feel good if you get
this you're gonna you know win that
peace how can we avoid being deceived
and is this a deception and how can we
get on that way the way of being of the
way of all the prophets of God and being
successful in this life in the hereafter
give us a blueprint well what this is if
a person realized that he has a purpose
in this life and that he has to leave it
to go to the next one then he would seek
this knowledge from the creator of the
heavens in u.s. when we read the last
revelation from a lot of the human
beings in the Quran and in the teachings
of the prophets allah allah allah
you'll have orders and many many orders
not to be deceived in the Koran it
clearly states the proper understanding
of things it will say that they say such
a thing but the truth is this it makes
the person see in the proper vision with
his heart what is right and what is
wrong so that he would have the patience
to be steadfast on the truth so not to
be deceived by holding fast to the
revelation from Allah in anything that
we have in this life that our physical
means that we have and that the means
that are mentioned in Revelations
physical means everybody agreed to it
and everybody believed in it but when it
comes to the means of Revelation the
rise and fall of nations
what is would benefit the person in this
life in the hereafter this is the only
place that we can get it is from the
revelation of the creator of the heavens
and earth from the Quran and the Sunnah
of the Prophet SAW Allah said so people
need to first think and see what is
their purpose of their life and they
need to search for the truth in that if
they are sincere in that search then
Allah will He will guide them to see the
truth and to read the revelation from
Allah so panel van and then they would
take matter seriously and they won't be
intoxicated any more they would see that
this is has a purpose in it and they
would hold fast to the religion of Islam
and not to be deceived by these
materialistic things Islam does not
forbid things that are materialistic we
eat we drink we get married we have
children we enjoy our life in this life
right because God created us in such a
way that we tend to like the things that
are present here it is not forbidden for
us it's not something that is a sinful
thing to enjoy our life but what is
sinful is to be forgetfulness to use the
beauty and the treasures in this life to
be instead of forgetfulness and not to
worship the creator of the heavens and
the earth
one important hadith and I believe I
mentioned it before that clarifies the
goals and means to us the prophets allah
sallam he said that allah subhanallah
versed in the ends and l-man lejos one
that we had revealed wealth money so
that the prayers are established so the
means is all thing that is present in
this life money and everything like that
there's nothing wrong with that
but should be it should be used in the
purpose of establishing
acts of worship and establishing this
purpose of life that should never escape
our minds and constantly a way to help
us to do that because there's so much
temptations to remember that one day we
have to leave this world that's why the
Prophet peace be upon him saw the lhari
sermon he ordered us to increase the
remembrance of death in another
narration it says because if you are in
time of ease and you might slip away
instead of forgetfulness the remembrance
of death would get you back on track and
if you are in misery you lost a loved
one you are you lost wealth or whatever
there is if you remember that it would
make it easy for you so in both ways the
person will be happier if he would
constantly remember that and then he
would be steadfast on the straight path
and worship the creator of the heavens
an irritant that makes a lot of sense
you got a lot of people out there that
now are procrastinating and they are not
adamant about searching for the truth
they might have tuned on and they're
watching the show now we want to create
this sense of urgency because when they
flip through the next channel they might
see some things that we would consider
unappropriate they might maybe go to
watch a football game basketball there's
nothing wrong with that but continuously
just doing this and spending time you
know working money and now they just
think that I'll deal with it when it
comes this attitude of not leaving off
sin not leaving off the things that your
conscience is already telling you that
it's bad just getting more into just
maybe the club scene going out with
friends partying dating fornicate
adultery you know gambling drinking
drugs and all these things and you know
death I'll just think about it when it
happens we want to try to get people on
the right path and can you give some
advice and some admonishment towards
this and then we're going to
glad-tidings a lost panel tyler the
creator of the heavens and the earth he
mentioned many verses in the quran that
talks about this fact in the human being
that warning them not to be deceived by
their wealth and their families and the
materialistic things in this life till
the moment of death comes and then the
person would say on a build-your-own
which means oh my Rob oh my lord let me
return back so that now after he see the
reality of things after we see the
angels of death coming to take his soul
now he wants to go back for what reason
not to accumulate more wealth not to be
instead of forgetfulness as he was
before but to do the things that would
benefit him in the everlasting life
so this is the time of regret that he
falls on to the person that is dying is
worse even than the physical punishment
being thrown into the Hellfire
we know what regret means and that's why
the person when he take the matter
seriously he would save himself from
this moment of regret at the moment of
death if you compare this moment to the
moment of someone else were a lost
planet allah says in the quran and by
the way there is no goodness in our life
unless we warn and give glad tidings not
from our own words but from the
revelation of Allah as The Lost Planet
Allah says in the Quran called in the
mountain very humble way I warn you by
the revelation nothing but the
revelation of Allah he said about those
who are believers in the Lavina coil or
a boon Allah some mystical those who
would say our Lord is Allah and they
were steadfast on the truth on the
submission of the to the creator of the
heavens and the earth in the Rodina
color abu omar from mystical
10/10 l0l amo Malaika the angels will
come down unto them at the moment of
death with two things and let a harmful
a dozen do not have the fear of what's
coming ahead which every human being
they fear death because they don't know
they do not know what's gonna happen to
them afterwards so the angels will come
and comfort them do not have the fear of
what's coming ahead and do not grieve
and be said of what you're leaving
behind and this at the moment of death
you find people worries of about what's
coming ahead and they have loved ones
they have children they have wealth and
they're very sad that they're leaving
this behind them but for the believers
and only for the believers they will be
giving the good news with the regarding
towards coming ahead and what's they're
leaving behind and then it would say
latter hvala terzano and we are your
supporters and you're the the ones that
supported you in this life and in the
hereafter and a lost final time I give
you the glad tidings of genda the
paradise that Allah had prepared for the
believers so for the believers while he
while he is dying at the moment of death
people around them are sad and crying
and things of that nature but for him he
doesn't want to come back
to this world he is happy he's content
and pleased with the reward someone lost
panel dad this amazing so this is for
the believers you said believers now
tell that person that who doesn't have
peace and who's being sincere with
himself and he is looking for peace and
he wants to be among the believers what
do we mean when we say a believer and
how could that believer now have peace
in his life the believer is the one that
subject himself to the mercy of the
creator of the heavens and earth and the
mercy of the creator of the heavens and
the earth is so vast
he's the one that created he's the one
that provides he's the one that with his
widdle I can raise my hand and I put my
hand down so that's why it's the worst
injustice that a person can do on the
face of earth is to worship other than
him
yea heaven is a carrier which is John
the Baptist and he said I'm one of the
messengers of Allah the messenger of
messengers of Allah Islam calling people
to the submission of Allah Spano Donaghy
called people with five words one of
which when he gathered the children of
Israel and he told them that Allah God
orders you to worship Him alone and not
to associate partners with him and he
gave him an example that pertained to
the environment that they were in
he said the example of this is that you
have a man that purchased a slave with
his own wealth and he told them that
this is my house and this is my work do
the work and give me what you earned but
instead the slave he worked but he gave
the earnings to someone else so he said
who among you would like for his slave
to do that right and then he said God
the creator of the heavens and the earth
created you and provided for you so why
do you worship other than him that's why
it's the worst injustice and that's why
when a person dies in such a state he
deserves to be punished because he
committed that injustice against his own
self when diversity of Allah is so vast
calling the people what all the things
that we see around us reminding us of
the creator of the heavens and the earth
just simply without no complications or
too much philosophy in it just worship
Him alone and this is what the message
of all Islam is and the final revelation
of a mother quran teaching you teaches
you this does not teach you to to be
blindly following to an
the human being or manipulated by the
ideas of human beings just basically
submit yourself to the creator of the
heavens and the earth and follow the
teachings of the last of the messengers
of allah prophet mohammed salah salem in
which his his teachings it has the
perfect way of life in economy in
politics and mannerism in acts of
worship in everything that you name it
you'll find a guidance in the quran and
then the sunnah of the prophet saw said
live in it and if you just don't want to
take my words for it go and read you for
yourself the truth has a characteristic
to it if you read it sincerely if you
see it you would find it true very clean
no doubt about it
falsehood you would find so much misery
and so much doubts and so much things in
your heart but for the truth it become
very clear to you so islam is clear
islam by doing islam you get that peace
that we're all looking for right this is
great thank you very much for being with
us surely and i'd like to thank you for
being with us again here on the Deen
show thank you all for the support of
hamdulillah all praises to the crater
that heavens and earth whose given us
disability to be with you and to sit
with people such as sheikh sudan and we
can benefit from and we'll let you
benefit from and you heard what he says
some great advice think about death and
be optimistic that there's something
better out there for you rather than
just this world so don't get caught up
with all the trappings and the delights
of this world put the time in and invest
now for the hereafter be the best human
being that you can be worshiping the one
god alone living like how he wants you
to live not living life according to
your desires and this is the way of life
that all the messengers of god taught
including the last and final message of
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
we hope to see you again next week on a
Deen show until then assalamu alaikum
peace be unto you eaves come easily
everybody sleeping
arise and ask Allah to forgive me Omar
you see all our you know all the sins I
do I turn to you to forgive my sin
tomorrow I'm missing for slave you don't
my love in Lord I'm the one runs away
all the guide me